uns hat er sich zu mir echt ich ja sonst
sonst wirst du ihn aber hey hey leute
was geht ab und jetzt bekommen bei einem
neuen jahr wollte ich hoffe natürlich
euch geht es gut das heutige video
entsteht mal wieder in kooperation mit
sagt ja ich durfte mir wieder einige
coole outfits raussuchen wir haben vor
ungefähr einem jahr schon mal die outfit
challenge gemacht dh der andere zieht
ein outfit an vom anderen kann ich heute
nicht so gut solche kehrt macht wir
haben vor einem jahr schon mal die
ausgetauscht challenge gemacht das heißt
der eine vom anderen die klamotten an
also zum beispiel alex hat für mich
outfit ausgesucht und ich werde genau
und alle outfits die heute sieht sind
von junkie hat zumindest das meister vor
wenn irgendein teil cool findet dann ist
es natürlich in der video scheidung
verlinkt wir sagen einfach mal schlug
der anfängt das heißt wenn ich jetzt
gewinne musst du anfangen schnick
schnack schnuck sieg würde ich mal sagen
stehen wir auf madame und ich zeige dir
mal das erste auto bild schreibt
natürlich auch dann geld in die
kommentare weil ich es am besten ist
also sie wird heute junge aufgetragen
ich mädchen outfits ich würde einfach
mal sagen wir fangen sportlich an ok und
zwar mit diesen sportlichen schuhen das
sind wirklich richtig sportliche schuhe
heute bist du doppelt so schnell als 60
43 dann hab ich dir dazu diese sporthose
von mike bestellt da die ist wirklich
extrem lässig und dieses album classic
longsleeve wie also ich habe den ganzen
jetzt noch eine cap hinzugefügt weil das
sagst du siehst aus wie das heißt jetzt
dumm an aber so wie so ein schlechter
porno anfang meist wenn so eine joggerin
oder so dann kommt so hey gar nicht
berlin was zu trinken haben oder so sie
das aber hey wer ist das denn jetzt
hallo
sagen was zu trinken bei ihnen haben
könnte ja kaum noch gleich mal rein
also das ganze sieht jetzt so aus ich
muss sagen an sich am gefällt mir das
eigentlich ganz gut
natürlich ist dieses ding für jungs der
rest die kappe ist gut so etwas sei ja
schon mal gar nicht so schlecht aus
würde sagen als nächstes bin ich hab
gelacht getrunken was willst du denn für
mich dabei ich habe für dich auch
sportlich ist aber ein pullover kleid
von junkie art richtig cool
deswegen also ist ein selbständiges
outfit man ist sehr schnell damit fertig
plus die reebok sich noch nicht rein in
eine schule welche genau was er gerade
tut sehr weh das ist auch meine beine
haare wachsen lassen
wer noch ein puzzleteil neben ich im
männer lockt rollenwechsel
wichtig dabei ist weil man muss das
einbehalten bis man das nächste outfit
anziehen kann also ja wie das sieht doch
so gar nicht schlimm aus der so nicht
aber man sieht ja nicht wie das hier
unten rum aus nicht bei mir ich habe
jetzt nichts ist was wirklich schönes
rausgesucht ich bin ein richtiger fan
von dem pulli und zwar die hose ist
jetzt nicht nur dank hat aber der
politik und in pully weil der ist mega
hit werden nicht bestellt hat da die
kontrolle über sein leben verloren
dieses teils hier hinten irgendwie
ziemlich wenn ich schon also ich muss
sagen so würde ich einfach mal locker
lässig jeden tag rausgehen so weißt du
dass du ein ganz typisches alex
ausschnitt nur die hose sie bei dir echt
nicht gut aus
ich möchte ich nicht erwarten irgendwie
warum ihr könnt gerne mal jetzt in die
kommentare schreiben wie geil findet ihr
diesen pulli ich finde wirklich genial
man sieht zwar aus sicht von der
müllabfuhr also man fällt halt wirklich
sehr auf wenn ihr aufwand wollte holt
euch den polit und wenn nicht dann auch
also ich finde das steht ja auch richtig
gut jetzt noch mal die haare kurz nach
hinten das kann sowohl jungs und mädchen
träumen
ich würde sagen ich bin wieder dran zeig
mir doch mal was du noch so aus ein
kleiner schrank gekramt
nein diese weise sie hiervon und ich
finde ich mir gut ist ein bisschen eng
lange hose die parodie sitzt ja richtig
eklig das quatsch eigentlich vor die
eier
naja ich hab ich einmal herum also die
hose kann ich auf jeden fall meinen
weiblichen zuschauer in dem film das
oberteil nicht und dann noch diese ja
genau
ja ich glaub so macht der kaputt die
jacke ja weil dieser bereit
also ich muss jetzt ich will jetzt hier
nicht zu nahe treten aber dieses sieht
bei mir jetzt echt nötig sei also ich
würde ich dieses auto sieht sich
bezeichnet aber das ist halt kein
schönes outfit aber ich weiß ganz
nützlich bei dir bin ich was auch ein
gesicht sie das macht ja irgendwie blöd
also ich finde das ist absolut grausam
ich habe auch noch nicht so getragen
aber ich kann es ja diesmal an wir
schauen jetzt ob das bei dir im
vergleich besser aussieht okay
zurück in meinem normalen outfit der den
gürtel hatte ich aber nicht ich finde du
siehst aus wie die franzosen da drin
sagt man branche wurde wo kate moss vor
1 haben wir noch oder ja ich glaube das
habe ich nämlich noch rausgesucht und
zwar mit meiner absoluten neuen
lieblings jacke ja ja das liegt dahinter
siehst du einfach mal an wir haben hier
eine wir haben hier eine ganz normale
jeans er seine skating dazu kommt ein
ganz normales weißes t shirt und diese
heftige weise ja ist ja an sich keine
jeansjacke aber im schnitt von einer
jeansjacke
noch heute wird uns also ich muss sagen
sieht eigentlich fast so aus wie bei mir
war das ist richtig gut aus aber sie
wieder sehr französisch aus so leute
macht euch gefasst auf das dritte outfit
ich bin das habe ich eigentlich am
besten hingekriegt die jacke genial ich
habe zwar keinen klagen von welcher
marke
die ist aber es natürlich verlinkt dann
hier darunter ein ganz normales t shirt
und so sieht das ganze dann aus also ja
ich würde sagen so viel dazu ich hatte
jetzt nur zwei outfits sogar drei wie
gesagt alle sachen in der wir schon
verlinkt lassen dann nach oben da wenn
wir das irgendwann nochmal machen sollen
und ich hätte mir eigentlich schlimmer
vorgestellt wir sehen uns dann
vielleicht morgen wieder ansonsten
morgen möchte noch etwas sagen
[Musik]